Speaker 1: One of the big sort of
storylines that we've been following
in particular over the last six months over the
last year, certainly been the kind of Trump era is
the reality that the modern American right wing
and the Republican Party have this list of stated
values, which mean almost nothing to them. As
soon as the values start to conflict with the
real world circumstances and the specifics
and the outcome that they want. They claim
to have values which they immediately abandon
as soon as those values are inconvenient
to the policy that they want, or to their
perspective on any kind of particular issue.
I have another example of this for you today,
which is Republican Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor
Greene, and this is really serious. The reason
that this is the first story today is that this
is really, really serious. Marjorie Taylor Greene
is now suggesting saying that there should be
a sort of grace period or a cooling off
period when Democrats move to a red state
from a blue state before they should be
allowed to vote. Now this goes against
Speaker 2: all election law,
Speaker 1: voting law, enfranchisement
of voters in the United States. It goes against
everything, not even from a logistical standpoint.
It goes again, even the idea, the values of how
this country works and how voting works. And it is
in fact, a sort of California version of the great
replacement theory, which comes from France, which
we're going to talk about in a moment. So let me
go through this piece by piece. Newsweek reporting
Marjorie Taylor Greene calls it wise to bar
Democrats who move to red states from voting. What
if red states and blue states were to divorce
each other? That's the word she's been using.
Representative Marjorie Taylor Greene called it
possible that people who move from a Dem state to
a Republican state would be barred from voting for
a temporary quote cooling off period. What is this
about? Well, California, Newsweek writes, has seen
an influx in people moving out of the state. Many
going to Texas and Florida, where residents get
more bang for their buck. However, some, including
Greene, have complained that those who are leaving
California, bringing their political beliefs with
them and potentially shifting the political
landscape. Yesterday, she posted on Twitter,
Brainwashed people who moved from California and
New York need a cooling off period. Her comment
was in response to a Twitter user who supports
who wrote he supports discriminating against
democratic transplants, including restricting
their ability vote to to vote for a period of
time. Marjorie Taylor Greene wrote on Twitter
All possible. So Pedro Gonzalez wrote, I support
actively discriminating against transplants
through legislation. They shouldn't be able
to vote for a period and they should have to pay
a tax for their sins. And Marjorie Taylor Greene
added to that, saying After Democrat voters
and big donors ruin a state like California,
you would think it wise to stop them from doing it
to another great state like Florida. Brainwashed
people that moved from California and New
York really need a cooling off period. This
is not legal. There is no legal basis for this.
They say that they are fighting the left's
voter fraud. Absentee ballot. Massive dumps of
votes. You guys know all this stuff, it's we're
sick of it by now and that they are all about
legal voting. Well, when you move to a new state,
you can legally vote there right away. There
is no legal basis. There is no constitutional
basis. There is no ideological. And I mean by
that the idea of the founders of this country,
by which you should be restricted from
voting when you move for some period of time.
And this is part of the full scale war on our
voting institutions that Republicans are waging.
This is not like an offhanded joke when we talk
about the coup attempt, when we talk about all
of that in the context of 2020. She believes
this. She believes this. And there's a really
good chance that many of other many of the other
Republicans and Trumpists believe it as well. We
can't laugh this off. They don't want democracy.
They want to pay lip service to the idea of a
democratic republic when in reality, what they
want is their sort of authoritarian, tyrannical
rule by what is increasingly a shrinking minority
ideologically. And that's an important thing
to remember ideologically, these people are
increasingly in the minority. This is the great
replacement theory applied to California. We've
talked about the great replacement theory before.
This is this comes from France. This is
a white nationalist conspiracy theory.
It was disseminated by the French author
Renaud Camu, and it states that with the
complicity or cooperation of replaced elites,
the white French population and white European
populations at large, this is from Wikipedia are
being demographically and culturally replaced with
non-European peoples. And at the time, from
the late 19th century when this originates,
they were talking about Arabs, Berbers, Turks
and sub-Saharan Muslims through mass migration.
We have talked about Tucker Carlson paying lip
service to a sort of American version of the great
replacement theory when he talks about immigrants
coming from typically central and South America,
making the country dirtier and poorer, as he says.
And the idea of Democrats wanting to bring
as many of these folks into the country
to get them to vote to win elections. That's the
great replacement theory just applied from 19th
century France in Europe to the United States in
the 21st century. Marjorie Taylor Greene is fear
mongering, is based on the same principle, which
is they're going to in this case, it's liberals.
And what what were the words that she used
brainwashed liberals who have committed sins
coming from California and New York to Florida and
Texas? And presume, you know, maybe her state of
Georgia as well? It's the same idea. It's the idea
of this plague or dirty infection from outside
coming in and replicating and taking over our
states like a parasite attaching itself to a host.
It is the exact same line of thinking 19th century
France. Tucker with brown people from Mexico,
Marjorie Taylor Greene, liberals from California
and New York, going to Florida and Texas.
And if we ignore it, if we ignore it, this stuff
will continue to take hold. Because if Marjorie
Taylor Greene is saying it, it's because a bunch
of her constituents already believe it and we
know that they do. So that's her idea. We are, of
course, horrified to see it. But at the same time,
need a strategy to activate against it, not
the voting piece. There's no legal basis for
what she wants, but these ideas are sadly
spreading. And not only are they spreading,
it's becoming more acceptable to say it in
public, which is a big part of the problem